alors c'est en tout cas toutes vos
entrées sur le ring sur de la musique de
joey starr et vous joey starr avec dadou
vous avez fait la musique un certain
nombre de morceaux du nouveau film
d'alain chabat qui s'appelle voilà donc
avec les robins jean rochefort gérard
depardieu et vous joey starr je suis une
apparition métier c'est bien à la
musique que vous avez fait c'est assez
d'atouts kapisa
bush
voilà c'est donc pour le film mots
d'alain chabat avec les robins on en
parlera plus longuement la la semaine
prochaine avec alain chabat et jean paul
rouve
alors c'est génial l'histoire c'est un
policier préhistorique complètement
handcent c'est assez génial
et vous où joey starr vous jouez vous
faites l'essayeur de gourdins change pas
trop mais c'est pas un rôle de
composition finalement ça s'est bien
passé le tournage ou un mois pour moi
c'était très court puisque je suis pas
chômé dietschy bongo l'a fait très vite
quoi inviter bien sûr il est bien le
film suit la vie non bah ouais bah de
façon je suis venu un peu le vent donc
que je vais pas dire qu'il pourrait nous
plumer par exemple j avais pas pensé
gens qui viennent pas dire ça va puis je
suis pas s'emballer rebonds à son style
alors vous dadou vous étiez tavares dans
gomez et tavarès les fameux ripoux j'ai
adoré ça vous le savez d'ailleurs
maintenant ils sont devenus gomes et du
bois pourquoi vous êtes parti parce que
justement ça partait d'une bonne
intention
assez assez saine et une intention assez
spontané et quand c'est devenu
une exploitation commerciale dans le bon
sens du terme
ça ne m'intéressait plus parce que
j'avais plus j'avais plus là j'avais pu
le spontané qui avait au départ mais il
est pas mal mais le même degré c'est du
bois non mais pas moi il n'y a pas de
problème sur soi mais moi je me sentais
vraiment de quoi vous sentez pas de
mentir en oui alors dadou après de
nombreux featurings vous avez fait un
premier album en avril 2003 qui
s'appelle france history x c'est sur
l'intégration
aujourd'hui et vous dit que finalement
l'intégration aujourd'hui c'est des
petites histoires
c'est exactement ainsi donc dans le
texte
je décris un peu une famille française
moyenne avec un fils qui est plus du rap
une fille qui sort avec ali qui est qui
fait le ramadan qui fait le ramadan est
pour moi l'intégration elle passe par
ces petites choses là est le poste par
deux histoires d'amour des fois elle
passe par plein de petites choses qui en
font des grandes
c'est vrai qu'en fait vous dit que
maintenant les jeunes ils savent ce que
c'est le ramadhan mashaal oblige là
dedans mais finalement il a pu la
télévision qui ne qui ne sait pas
comment ça se passe quoi je pense je
pense vraiment toute la nuit ils
continuent à se faire dans la rue avec
des gens au jour le jour
un écueil qu'aujourd'hui synthétiser
l'information à des faits divers et en
faire une
une peinture sociale c'est un peu
s'éloigner de la réalité
alors votre prochain album va sortir
cette année vous viendrez nous en parler
j'espère bien mais j'espère bien
openlink à ta voix l'a très bien merci
bien alors vous dites oncle est mon rêve
c'est le jazz
mon inspiration au niveau du flou c'est
miles davis vous pensé aller plus vers
le jazz dans l'avenir - vers le rap
disons que je pense à faire beaucoup
plus de musique en général et de
vraiment démontré que l'europe ça a été
commandée sur la musique de mon époque
ouais et que et que je respecte vraiment
ce qui s'est passé avant parce qu'il ya
une histoire avant le rap on peut
arriver et prétendre révolutionner
quelque chose donc c'est vraiment faire
le relais entre ce qui s'est passé et ce
qui se passe raconte alors j'aurai
comment ça va vous savez que les gens
vous aiment de plus en plus vous êtes
bientôt dans le top 50 des français
préféré des français vous le savez ça je
suis pas je hais capitation pâtit moins
cette fois mon truc énorme